[Music]
hi
i'm bridget hillier i'm one of the
organizers at strange loop
in this series we've been talking to
previous speakers
but now that we have a program for this
year we're talking to some future
speakers
strange loop is on in person this year
it's september 30th through october 2nd
uh 2021 in st louis missouri usa
you can find out more information and
get tickets at the website
thestrangeloop.com also this year we
have a virtual option so if you aren't
able to make it in person
you can still be part of the conference
so you can also find out
information about that on the website
today i am delighted to have tejas
chopra here who will be speaking this
year in
october and the name of his talk is
carbon footprint aware
software development thanks for being
with me today tejas will be nice to talk
to you
yes same here bridget and uh thank you
everyone for listening in
and i'm excited to talk about carbon
footprint and software
so today i'd just like to talk about
some background and some things around
carbon footprint aware software
development so my first question
when i saw your talk and that the
abstract what
i was first curious about is what led
you to be interested
in carbon footprint aware software
development was it
something you'd worked on you know some
knowledge you had
something in your background yeah that's
a great question i think it's a
it's a series of steps that led me to
where i am the first thing i would say
is that i got interested in bitcoin
in the year 2013 2014 just when it was
very nascent and one of the things with
bitcoin
was that oh it's an energy gobbler so
i started reading more about it more
about proof of work
and i saw that yes in fact bitcoin
actually consumes a lot of energy
today and that actually led me to take a
step back
and look at other areas of my life
where you know i'm seeing carbon
footprint increase in carbon footprint
and there are two ways really one thing
is as
a human being you use a lot of services
you use your smartphone you use the
internet
you use a car so those are things that
you can
definitely choose to buy stuff
appropriately
and the other thing is as a software
developer you work on
software and it's in when i try to
research more into it i realize that
four percent of the total carbon
footprint on this planet
is contributed by software so i know
that it is not
four percent seems very minuscule
compared to you know 20
30 that we have out there with cars with
with you know agriculture and other
things
so but if you can make a dent in that
four percent
because that is completely in your
control that would really go a long way
in trying to make this planet better
so that was what was the motivation that
i had and then i connected it back to
what i had learned in school
so i'm from carnegie mellon university
in school we had
lectures around you know how can you
write more efficient software
and then i try to club these two
thoughts together can we
write software that is efficient and
better for the environment and there are
simple techniques as software engineers
that you can employ in your day-to-day
life so that's where you know these dots
connected and that's how i got
interested
into it and i've been using it in my
work since that point on and i am a
strong advocate of you know having
making a change in the environment
because we should always leave back
the world better than what we got it so
that's the motivation
so bitcoin i i'm not surprised to hear
that that that was an inspiration there
when people think about this topic
that's you know the first thing they
think of because
you know there's a lot of talk about it
so based on what you've learned
what do you think the hope is for
bitcoin for what could be done
there to reduce the carbon footprint
sure so one thing is that there is also
a misnomer out there
that bitcoin energy is like bitcoin is
really bad for the environment
it is bad because it uses a lot of
energy but if you compare it to the
industries it is trying to disrupt such
as traditional banking or
gold the energy usage in those areas or
those industries is still much higher
than bitcoin
and if you look at what the aim of
bitcoin is it is
to actually give financial independence
to people that are not
really reached out by traditional
banking so it really will make people's
lives better
so in that sense i still feel that you
know the energy usage in bitcoin is a
problem
but there are far bigger problems as
well out there for ener for reducing the
energy consumption that's
the first point uh the second point is
that yes proof of work is bad for the
environment
so it is unfortunately the way bitcoin
is designed
it will keep using proof of work there
are alternators such as ethereum
which use proof of stake and with
ethereum 2.0
the amount of energy will go down by
99.9 percent
when s 2.0 just comes out so
so that's the other thing i have seen
that recently bitcoin
proof of work algorithms like the mining
farms and all they are using renewable
energy sources
at locations where previously we were
not able to tap into them
so a very good example is el salvador
which is introducing bitcoin they
actually want to mine
it using the volcano that they have so
energy from the volcano
so i think these are interesting ideas
that people are coming up with
to circumvent the problems and these
ideas can also be applied in other
industries
so it's not really a lose-lose i still
feel that there is
something to gain from our experience
with bitcoin and with
increase in usability increase in
scalability things will get better
that's what i think yeah it's nice to
talk to somebody who
has some real perspective on on it and
has thought through the problems
as opposed to just bitcoin is bad for
the environment
what do we do so you work at netflix and
it's i think anybody would hear that and
hear you talk about
uh carbon um footprint where software
development would then have the question
well
what is netflix doing and and if
when you're thinking about things like
that uh like bitcoin
netflix has the potential to have a lot
of impact
if they were to employ uh things that
improved their carbon footprint so how
has that affected
how you look at how software development
works at netflix
and this is a very pertinent question
because especially
now that we are all in remote work in
some ways the streaming industry has
boomed we have so many streaming
providers and netflix has 200 million
subscribers 200 million plus subscribers
so any indent that we can make in this
space
goes a long way to improve the
environment and it's also a very
pertinent time actually because
recently the carbon trust group did a
study it's an independent group
and they claimed in the study that an
hour of streaming a netflix movie
in the uk the amount of energy that it
uses
is equivalent to boiling a kettle for
six minutes or
like popping four bags of popcorn in a
microwave
so in that sense this has and just to
give you numbers there
it's 55 grams of carbon dioxide released
uh in the air by streaming a netflix
movie for an hour
50 percent of it is contributed by the
last mile which is the user's phone or
user's device
which really you cannot control beyond
an extent 50
of it is then the network infrastructure
the data centers
the rest request calls all of those
taking up energy and netflix has gotten
really better at it because
at the start of the year it was around
100 grams
of carbon dioxide for an hour at least
by some study and now it is down to 55
grams
and it really has gotten better over the
years so we are
aiming to be greenhouse emission neutral
i think that's the word by 2022.
so in that sense we we are as a company
very invested in you know making the
environment better
and netflix again has two parts to it
there is a physical production where you
actually produce movies and then there
is a streaming part of it
the physical production is the one that
generates a lot more
carbon dioxide or has a bigger energy
footprint than the streaming part
so to offset that we would then buy
credits carbon credits and that's how
we'll get carbon neutral
so that's what netflix is doing on that
front and i personally work on the
storage infrastructure side so i work
as a part of a team that builds storage
solutions for
netflix studios and streaming platforms
and we have
petabytes to exabytes of storage that we
deal with at netflix
so what we try to do in our day-to-day
work is you know write
efficient code that reduces the
footprint of storage in the cloud
which effectively then boils down to how
much energy gets used in the cloud
one thing is that you pay for it and you
have money for it and that's fine like
netflix has money
but the other thing is is this good for
the environment and that's the bigger
motivation for us
as engineers here also in my day-to-day
work i'm
translating all these ideas into
software techniques for example
a simple thing like removing dead code
right you may think that
fine if you don't remove it it's just
lying there but it actually takes up
energy cycles to you know process it and
not actually
execute that that code so in some ways
these little steps having event driven
architectures versus polling based
architectures
they are things that reduce your cpu
usage and then translate into
a better experience for the environment
so these are things that you know on top
of my head that i can think of that
we're doing as engineers here
well that's great to hear that netflix
and especially with the
those aggressive targets like by 2022
that's that's
that's great to hear that's comforting
so some of the things you've talked
about
with the various points at which there's
energy consumption
looking ahead to what the techniques are
for
carbon um footprint aware software
development
something i find as a software developer
in in doing
profiling of things one of the real big
principles that you run into
and and what you run into in practice is
knowing what you're actually measuring
you know
if you if you're measuring you know cpu
cycle or
memory usage of something it's
when you do the measurement are you
actually measuring the thing that you
have
that you can make an impact on um so
thinking about that what are your
thoughts about
how what metrics there would be to
see that you're improving things and
then how do you actually
do the measuring on that that's a great
question
and that's actually what i aspire to do
as part of you know my job where today
when you write code
you have unit tests that catch your bugs
and you have integration tests so you
you deploy your code there are a bunch
of tests that run and then you know that
whether it's good or not
and i aspire to make a framework where
you know it's not just
uh functionally correct code but
environmentally
good code so you will have a framework
or a series of tests that you can run
that like you said measure the memory
usage measure the cpu cycles of your
code
measure the amount of spin spinning of
your like if you have spin locks
anywhere or
uh detecting those kind of things in
your code and give you alternatives
for those also stuff what compilers do
these days right
loop unrolling uh some of these things
that you can do on your end i think
these would be good starting points
and then you can use a lot of static
analysis tools that are already
available in coding so
they would be a great starting point and
then uh like you said you know flame
graphs are a good way to know which
function is being hit the most
and you can then get into that like
which particular function needs to be
optimized the most
for energy so those are some of the
tricks that you can start off with
so one of the things that has got me
interested in this topic is
i did a lot of research and thought a
lot about
changing jobs or you know moving in a
professional direction to do something
towards um having some impact on
climate change you know not that i was
going to figure out anything that solved
anything but you know just try to move
over into some industry that
has more of an impact and in the course
of doing that i found out a lot and and
made some
decisions based on that but i also
talked to a lot of people a lot of
software developers
in my network who are interested in the
same thing i've heard this from so many
people
um how do you think taking a look
at the impact on climate change via the
lens of
carbon footprint aware software
development how does that
what what advice would you give somebody
who's thinking about
that would it be better to say go work
at tesla and help them produce electric
cars which just has direct impact on
climate change
or using what you know about software
development
to make an impact on how software and
services
impact on climate change like put
another way
if i go work at facebook and i know
these methods
and i can reduce their carbon footprint
by point zero zero whatever one percent
given how how big their services versus
doing something that's direct like
electrical
cars or solar panels what advice would
you give somebody in in
weighing those two options sure sure and
i i truly believe that uh
electric cars are the future if you look
at the world
uh 40-50 years from now uh what will the
world look
like i think it'll be electric cars
it'll be cars that drive themselves
probably not even cars i don't even know
what all will be there but i
i do believe that you know at that scale
it would make a lot of sense for anyone
to you know look for a career
in building those so definitely that
would be the first pick
but a lot of us don't have options
because electric cars haven't reached a
lot of countries in the world people do
not have the technology
to get there yet so do you as an
engineer
wait till that comes over or do you try
to move the needle however tiny
do you know do your little bit in your
day-to-day work and
facebook is a great example right like
if you look at whatsapp the number of
people it touches is like 2 billion plus
in the world so if you look at 0.001
percent
of that it's still a bigger number
compared to let's say tesla two years
back where it was just still a tiny
fraction of the number of cars or
emissions that happened i agree that
with time we will
come to a place where we would everyone
would be working on something that
is directly correlated to the
environment so if i was sitting in
california i would prefer tesla
going and making electric cars but if
i'm sitting in some remote corner of the
world
where i don't have many options i can
still try to work at some other company
and write software
something that i live and breathe in a
way that you know can help the
environment to move the needle a little
bit
so i think no matter where you
are you can always uh find a way to do
the right thing
so yeah that's some really good
perspective
something i've continued to think about
and you know a lot of people i know
do thank you so much jjs i this is this
has been great
really interesting topic and i'm very
much looking forward to your talk
can't wait to see you in person at
strange loop in october
thanks so much for agreeing to speak at
the conference
absolutely and i look forward to talking
to everyone and
finally coming out of this pandemic and
meeting in person
[Music]
you